you found a good group of guys a long
time ago buddies of yours and you always
work with them so that you can kind of
keep yeahi going is that right I guess
so
maybe used to keep the quality going
maybe it's because we don't have any
other friends except the people that I
know if the guys I work with on pretty
much everything our guys that I met my
like freshman year of college they're
all college buddies they're all college
buddies from the writers to the sound
guy to the camera operators the
production designer it's all guys I met
when I was 18 years old and I have not
made any new friends since then well
it's it's working for you whatever
you're doing I guess ya know it's funny
because there are everyone has a
different method but a lot of shows I
like to have like a retreat a
collaborative sort of creative retreat
yeah where they take the staff and they
they go off someplace and everyone gets
to have some together time to help the
creativity do you guys ever do that you
know we have our own version of that
like I met all these guys at art school
we went to an art school in North
Carolina so they're all weirdos and we
uh we kind of have that retreat it's
more of we call it a like a Vision Quest
we we go out to LA we can a Vision Quest
a lot of pressure on you learn a lot we
would go out every since I moved to LA
we would go out the same group of guys
every year to Joshua Tree and and we
would eat mushrooms out there and try to
expand her and then I had a kid I don't
do anything cool anymore but the yeah
but it were I mean did it did it feel
like it worked like you take mushrooms
you're out at Joshua Tree did you feel
like you experienced things you
definitely would come back feeling a
little different there was a one of the
last vision quests I remember was uh we
had gone out there and it was late at
night and there most people were
partaking in the quest and there was a
few people were just watching the Vision
Quest so a couple people did not did not
imbibe the know they had sense and uh
and we uh and I was kind of by myself
and I looked out over the ridge the
mountain and I was like that's a
humongous white light coming right
towards us what is that and I started
looking I called all my other friends
like look at this light it's coming
towards us and everyone's like it's a
UFO oh my god
this is a UFO for five minutes like here
it comes we're about to find out what is
out there it's coming towards us
everyone's hugging each other and we're
hey we're saying goodbye hi has this
thing approaches and then one of the
guys who was just watching us was like
guys that's the moon and I think at that
point we kind of realized you know we're
not really expanding our minds we're
actually just becoming dumber doing this
that's usually what happens usually I
was riding my bike not too long ago and
up and around my neighborhood and I came
across these guys in a car and they were
like sir sir help us we're tripping on
shrooms and I had the helmet on the
glasses and they didn't know with me so
actually they said please call the
police please call the police so I
called the police and the police finally
showed up and I said okay can I go now
cuz I babysat him for a while and they
still didn't see who I was and then I
left these guys were freaked out and I
later heard the police told them Conan
O'Brien mushrooms they're like God
you other spirit guides I should have
done it taking off the helmet right
there and then like UTV's alive man I've
been watching you and watching you all
this time man
you